In this video, we'll discuss collisions and how to set them up properly with Datasmith
imports.
When we first import geometry into Unreal, including with Datasmith, we are often presented
with a checkbox that asks us if we would like to generate collisions.
We also have the ability to add in custom collisions using simple primitives like boxes
or spheres or capsules, as well as the ability to create auto-convex collisions.
A complicated piece of geometry using its own geometry for collisions can get expensive,
so when possible, try to keep collisions simple.
And note, as seen in this example, that a single object can have multiple collisions,
so I find it pretty useful to be able to use some combination of the simplified collision
options here to create a custom set of different primitive shapes to conform to the collision
shape that I need for a particular project.
As a quick example, let's go back into our project and set up a couple collisions.
If we want to see the collision already existing in our map, we can go to View Modes and click
on Player Collision, not Visibility Collision, and if we see that it's black like this,
we know no collision has been set up yet.
So let's use the same piece of wall geometry we were already looking at, double click here,
and we can see, if we click on Collision, that because we don't have an option for removing
collision, we know that no collision is set up yet.
This is a pretty simple box, so we could go ahead and do a box simplified collision, which
will adapt and conform to the geometry in a nice clean, simple way.
Go ahead and save that.
And now, if we go back to that View Mode, we'll see this one object shows up as a collider.
Let's try doing a custom one for the ground.
So instead of automatically setting it up, we can go into the static mesh here, and we
could go ahead and add still a box, but we might start to adjust a few features of it,
and we can move it up and down by grabbing it and changing it like this.
We looked at a side view, something orthographic.
And of course, if we wanted to build this up from a number of pieces, especially imagining
if the terrain was higher, we might actually do this in a couple parts.
So perhaps we might have one piece of geometry over here, and I could hold down Alt, just
like in the regular editor, to duplicate another piece of geometry here.
I could even rotate it if I needed to, and start to build this up from a number of different
services, all depending on what level of precision you need.
Perhaps you're going to have a basement level, and you need the collision to be clear, so
you have easy access to the basement area without being blocked by that additional collision.
Or maybe you just have floors that you want to set up in a particular way.
You might also get into the world of physical materials and creating friction in certain
ways.
There's a lot of ways this can become more advanced if you like, but I'll go ahead and
save that.
And then once again, just check on our player collision, and we can see everything showing
up there in the shapes of the collision we've done.
Now if we want to set this up in a bulk way for everything in our scene, we can go ahead
and find the folder where this lives, mHouse, find it here, then we can go over into Geometries,
and we can select All and right-click, and we'll go to Asset Actions and Edit Selection
in Property Matrix.
From here, we have all of these objects selected.
We can do Control-A to confirm, and then for Collision, we can tell the collision complexity
to use complex collision as simple.
From there, if we save, we'll now find that if we go to our collision view, everything
now has colliders.
And then if we wanted to go and disable colliders in certain places like the door, we could
just open up those particular pieces of Geometry and scroll down, and there's actually two
choices here.
We could change our collision preset to No Collision, or just simply change this back
to Project Default.
Save that, and then we can see we have a nice opening where we can move into the project,
bump into furniture, and climb upstairs.
And though noting that we are adding additional complexity, especially on the CPU, to have
such complicated geometry here for collision when that might not be necessary, this could
probably be done as a cube or a few cubes, all dependent on the needs of your project.
In the next video, we'll look at how to optimize our project further.